Questa sera vorrei parlarvi di alberi
e di città
E perché è importante
immaginarci una relazione tra queste due
diversissime sfere che appartengono una
alla natura e una costruito per farlo
vorrei immaginare Innanzitutto un
pianeta senza alberi senza arbusti senza
Prato
è un'immagine distopica ci dà molto
fastidio fa parte di quei quelli
immaginari come i film in cui a un certo
punto vediamo un pianeta del tutto
ghiacciato o un pianeta che va
completamente a fuoco
un pianeta che soffre magari delle
terribili pandemie qualcosa di veramente
terrificante
e poi vorrei immaginare un pianeta senza
di noi che è altrettanto terrificante
un pianeta dove ci chiediamo Come stanno
gli alberi arbusti senza di noi
stanno benissimo
stanno benissimo e anzi se vediamo in
quei luoghi
abbandonati non remoti semplicemente
dove noi abbiamo fatto un passo indietro
ci siamo allontanati la natura ha
ricominciato a crescere flora e fauna
hanno ripreso possesso e crescono
Allora se abbiamo stabilito che noi
abbiamo bisogno di alberi di foreste di
nelle città in particolare perché questo
non avviene
Eppure ci sono molte teorie che ci
raccontano che noi discendiamo dagli
alberi qualcuno ancora lì e
in questa
discesa dove noi abbiamo iniziato a
costruire i primi insediamenti abbiamo
iniziato a costruire le nostre capanne
poi le nostre città abbiamo portato gli
alberi vicino a noi li abbiamo portati
e li abbiamo addomesticati per stare
vicino a noi perché sono una fonte di
cibo Perché servono per riscaldarci
Perché servono come materiale da
costruzione sono tantissimi usi
E allora
nella continua evoluzione abbiamo siamo
passati da una dimensione primaria
Quindi questi servizi che gli alberi ci
danno la dimensione invece
più ricreativa una dimensione in cui
abbiamo bisogno di una dimensione
estetica della natura
e ci sono molti esempi in cui ad esempio
le nostre Elite che hanno governato la
società per molti secoli hanno costruito
parchi giardini
dove proprio andare a vivere in questa
natura In questo caso molto più
addomesticata e in quella meno
addomesticata seppure controllata con
anche con recinti i luoghi di
cacciagione
e poi
con la rivoluzione industriale dove lì
grande processo di inurbamento delle
città abbiamo allontanato la natura
Abbiamo cominciato a produrre
L'inquinamento è cresciuto moltissimo
e lo spazio della natura si è ridotto
perché le case le fabbriche si sono
addossate l'una all'altra la densità
in questo periodo abbiamo scoperto
che ci sono degli virus dei batteri e
che le malattie si trasferiscono proprio
in una dimensione da miasma a una
dimensione di scoperta delle
epidemiologia
e proprio questa condizione di
trasferimento da non si sa a si sa molto
bene dove le condizioni ambientali sono
molto rilevanti Questa è una mappa
prodotta nel 1854 da questo studioso Jon
Snow che scopre che il colera
si passa attraverso l'acqua e proprio
perché
l'incidenza di abitanti in questo luogo
Scoprono che
bevendo in un'unica Fontana
Ben si ammalano e quindi proprio il
comprendere questa questa relazione in
un ambiente molto denso riesce a
cominciare a costruire questa dimensione
di causa effetto proprio in luoghi molto
densi
e in questo periodo In questa stagione
nelle città si cominciano a comprendere
proprio soprattutto per l'inquinamento
per questa dimensione anche delle
malattie che la natura è necessaria
quindi l'abbiamo allontanata l'abbiamo
dobbiamo riportarla allora nel Regno
Unito cioè in questo momento delle
Garden City e nelle città
la costruzione di grandi parchi di
grandi parchi all'interno delle città il
cui più famoso è sicuramente Central
Park a New York
da allora i parchi E ancora oggi sono un
grande elemento di importanza nelle
nostre città
e lo è perché lo sono perché sono quei
luoghi
democratici dove persone di ogni ceto
razza si incontra non necessariamente si
parla ma si incontra in un unico luogo e
sono anche quei luoghi dopo il primo
lockdown del coronavirus dove ci siamo
incontrati anche noi quando ci siamo
siamo usciti non si sapeva esattamente
dove stare dovevamo stare comunque
distanti dovevamo stare nello spazio
aperto e ci sono tantissimi studi che
raccontano che i parchi nelle città sono
stati i luoghi più frequentati E allora
gli alberi ritorniamo
agli alberi
vivono una nuova stagione in questo
momento dopo che appunto hanno passato
tutte queste relazioni con noi Adesso
hanno un'altra una nuova modo in cui noi
li guardiamo li viviamo li immaginiamo
in un momento così complicato quello
della crisi climatica Ci aspettiamo
degli alberi che ci aiutino a ridurre
L'inquinamento dell'aria
a stoccare il carbonio
a ridurre il ruscellamento Cioè quanto
L'acqua scorre nelle nostre città è
troppo in fretta invece gli alberi ci
aiutano a portare l'acqua nel sottosuolo
a ridurre le isole di calore il caldo
che nelle nostre città soprattutto
quelle più impermeabilizzate cioè
abbiamo alzato l'asticella Ci aspettiamo
sempre di più degli alberi
Eppure se io adesso dicessi
cambiamo facciamo
nelle nostre città
facciamo cantiamo gli alberi facciamo
forestazione urbana e tutti potremmo
dire sì
Eppure l'attitudine che noi abbiamo
verso verso gli alberi non è proprio
così diretto
perché quando entriamo nello specifico e
dobbiamo trovare i luoghi dove piantare
allora
vediamo alcune
perplessità e ve le voglio raccontare
immaginatevi che siamo in un parcheggio
siamo in estate fa molto caldo
arriviamo con l'auto Dobbiamo
parcheggiare
chi di noi non parcheggerebbe la
macchina sotto l'albero Tutti di solito
ci si picchia per arrivare proprio sotto
quell'albero che ci permette di
raffrescare un minimo l'abitacolo
e se non c'è l'albero ovviamente apriamo
le portiere Facciamo partire l'aria
condizionata perché insomma fa caldo e
lo vorremmo tantissimo vorremmo
tantissimo che qualcuno avesse piantato
degli alberi intorno al parcheggio
quegli alberi ci servono
prendiamo la nostra macchina e andiamo a
casa o in ufficio e siamo in un viale
dove non c'è verde
tendenzialmente anche abbastanza
difficile parcheggiare
c'è una buona notizia Il comune ha
deciso di fare un viale alberato e
quindi alcuni parcheggi dovranno essere
sacrificati perché viene liberato vuol
dire che inseriamo degli alberi siamo
sempre noi ma io sono sicura che per
perdere un parcheggio non siamo così
pronti a inserire gli alberi perché
insomma queste sono delle priorità delle
comunità non siamo pronti a lasciarci
indietro un parcheggio per un albero lo
stesso accade in altri ambienti nelle
scuole diciamo dobbiamo piantare gli
alberi nelle scuole perché è molto
importante i nostri bambini devono
riconoscere l'importanza del verde degli
alberi
però gli alberi perdono le foglie vanno
nelle grondaie
cadono a terra bisogna pulire
Mio figlio è allergico a quella specie
le radici sono pericolose alla fine non
si piantano Ce ne sono tantissimi di
esempi in cui noi li amiamo un po' da
lontano ma quando sono veramente vicini
insomma la situazione è più complicata
Eppure gli studi ci dicono
che gli alberi riducono la pressione
arteriosa quando camminiamo in una in un
bosco in una parco ma anche non viale
alberato se facciamo attività fisica nel
verde gli studi scientifici ci dicono
che c'è una significativa riduzione
della pressione
una riduzione della frequenza cardiaca
una riduzione nel colesterolo
una riduzione nelle nascite premature
quindi donne che sono esposte al verde
hanno questi benefici
il 16% di riduzione della mortalità
cardiovascolare
vi ho un po' convinto che diciamo
più è necessario forse ci avviciniamo se
non fosse così ci sono altri studi che
ci dicono
che anche dal punto di vista psicologico
gli alberi ci fanno benissimo
perché il nostro individuo Questo è uno
studio di Wilson ci dice che
l'attrazione della nostra specie nei
confronti della natura fa sì che ci
rilassiamo moltissimo come come specie
umana perché siamo immersi perché
usciamo perché non siamo nel nostro
Habitat quotidiano e quindi Trasformiamo
le nostre azioni e viviamo in una
condizione nuova e lo stesso lo dice
kaplan dove studia che le
caratteristiche della natura influenza
sull'uomo hanno benefici nel sul nostro
essere e che la natura ha un effetto
ristoratore in particolare da eventi
stressanti siamo stressati andiamo
facciamo una passeggiata nel verde
questa dimensione di guardare
soprattutto ad elementi naturali vivi e
quello che ci fa stare bene
E se lo facciamo e se abbiamo parchi
viali Alberati se abbiamo delle
condizioni ambientali di verde
favorevole siamo più propensi ad andare
a piedi
ad attraversare questi spazi usciamo
dalle nostre case e andiamo a piedi in
bicicletta e questo fa bene alla nostra
salotti fisica alla nostra salute
mentale al nostro portafoglio e anche al
pianeta
E allora se spero di avervi un po'
diciamo convinto di più
al fatto che gli alberi non sono
qualcosa di utile sono qualcosa di
necessario quindi dobbiamo passare da un
tema di
utile Sì ma ci sono altre priorità a
importante tanto da farne la nostra
priorità
e se siamo convinti di questo
e se dobbiamo piantare lo dobbiamo fare
come un atto di tutti Non bastano alcuni
e questo è un altro un passaggio molto
importante questo tipo di azioni deve
essere fatto da istituzioni pubbliche da
istituzioni privati dai cittadini dalle
associazioni da esperti e non esperti
dall'accademia dalla società sono tutti
che lavorano per questo sistema e vorrei
concludere dicendo
che gli alberi non ci salveranno da soli
Evidentemente non sono l'unico L'unico
obiettivo l'unica tecnologia che ci
salverà Se pensate che il 3% della
superficie terrestre è occupata dalle
città e quel 3% consuma il 70% produce
75% di carbonio Voi capite che la
disparità è troppo grande gli alberi che
noi piantiamo quelli piccoli ci mettono
del tempo a crescere
non possiamo immaginare che è 10 100
1000 alberi che cambiano il destino ma è
questa attitudine incrementale che ci
permette di cambiare
e la sfida della forestazione urbana
attraverso la pianificazione che guarda
al presente ma anche al futuro delle
città e quello che ci permette di
immaginare
che facciamo qualcosa oggi che lo
facciamo tutti i giorni e che questo può
aiutare migliorare
le nostre città migliorare la qualità
delle nostre vite e forse anche
migliorare un po' il pianeta Grazie
[Applauso]